and
now that we know what is the right kind
of skill set that is required for
industrial research how can someone
acquire these
what kind of internships or job
opportunities should one look for in
such scenarios so now we would be
starting with our academic panel
discussion and i would like to welcome
our academic panelists dr kalyani karla
dr shibi and dr sunari khandra dr
kalyani owns a phd in biochemistry and
is a mentor at mentors high and dr
sonali holds a phd in cancer biology and
she's the ceo of kiki
minds thank you sunalika and uh
hello everyone um we are now heading
towards the
uh industry panel discussion and uh i
think uh what nidhi
did was like uh to give us this amazing
platform uh with her energetic talk and
nidhi as you are also part of this panel
and if you can also join in so
that
that was a great uh discussion and we
covered like a lot of points that we
were hoping to discuss and uh actually
that makes sense now to uh go into this
next
session which is to discuss some of the
opportunities that are there and also uh
to summarize some of the points that we
have uh that we have put together let me
share my
uh my uh
presentation
so uh we kind of
been discussing here for since yesterday
about how the academic research is
shaping up in india we have had great uh
experts a great lesson and also
participants from all around the globe
listening from the experts about how
their research has influenced plus what
they see that how like bioinformatics
can be a part and can be integrated into
several ways and the pathways uh for
students to learn about it and uh to
maybe transition to the to the industry
by having those understanding of those
hard hard skills that nidhi was just
talking about but um we would want to
start with this discussion that uh as an
into industry as an entrepreneur as a
leader how do you see this
industry evolving and that brings me to
my like next slide which is like uh
this recent report
about the
healthcare being reinvented in india and
the numbers around it and the different
areas where
the
uh the survey sees that there isn't a
huge application and hence the
opportunity so uh again like uh you know
about make in india programs uh from
indian soil that have nurtured much of
this biotech programs but somehow it
remains nascent so what is then the
solution like uh there are tech parks
and i know the one that had opened up
and hyderabad and sonali has been part
of it so like industrial collaborations
silicon valley like ecosystems so uh i
mean with that question and with that
note i would want to maybe go to sonali
first and uh start a discussion about
this current situation
and uh where are we and where do you see
that where are the opportunities
for the future of in indian healthcare
sector and also for those students who
are now freshers and who are
listening for the first time about
something like this
hi
good evening everyone am i audible
yes
okay thank you thanks thanks a lot mohit
for giving this opportunity uh really
um so glad uh sharing uh you know my
evening talking
to all the other along with all the
other panelists and
it's really a great platform and the
work what you guys are doing uh
educating young uh you know
individuals and and all uh talents uh
and of course you know giving them a
path or the direction moving forward
next what's happening in the industry so
that's that's really commendable because
at least if i remember uh 10 years back
there were no one to show us the path so
so i would say that you know uh you guys
are really doing good job for the next
uh you know the millennial or the or the
future scientist
so yeah coming back to the investment in
this space and the the the industry
itself how it is going and i think um
you know
i can take my own example and by the the
whole opportunity we have seen and we
have invested in this space and we have
you know uh and that the whole genesis
of ikey minds happen so just for the
people who are not aware uh you know i
come from uh life sciences background
have my phd postdoc in that but of
course always
felt the gap and and always felt that
there was you know the missing uh things
uh which was definitely you know
bringing more technology into it and um
then i worked with a couple of you know
uh
tech uh startups uh some vc firms to
understand you know how the whole space
moving in this like the medic space how
the investments are coming and how the
business model should be built because
when you're a researcher you just focus
on the science you have never been
allowed to even look at the business
part of it right like how to actually
take the whole science to the market i
think that's the most uh saddest part of
it because you know as a researcher you
don't really look at who's going to use
it who's who's who's my customer
you don't use this word at all who's the
customer who's the user you just do your
research right so so i think
that's the whole change in your mindset
your perspective when you come to you
know the industry and you look at who's
going to use this and when you know that
who's going to use this your entire
perspective towards building it
completely changes because you know
there's a person there's a cert there's
a patient or there is a user who's going
to directly use my product or my
services so your perspective change you
know this is no more just for you know
mice or rat or for animals you you're
going to really change people's life
you're going to change you're going to
touch humans right so that's that's a
huge change uh which you see you know
from your academic industry but coming
back to your question yes and then we
started you know bringing more uh
questioning more like how we can bridge
this gap between you know
people who come from life sciences have
no understanding of technology and on
the other hand people who are tech who
are really good you know coding skills
and and techies but they don't
understand the domain so so how do we
bring these two words and when i was a
triple i t i was heading the innovation
center we had amazing startups you know
uh but all they were like tech people
they have absolutely no they jump into
startups you know kind of you know
trying to solve what what is required
and what is the admits need in
healthcare but the challenge was because
they don't come from domain it's always
tech first
tech first kind of you know approach but
that's how it it doesn't work that way
because it has to be a problem
first approach like what's the demand
what is the challenge right and then you
try and solve that problem using
technology so so it's always the other
way
but i think the missing thing was you
know having that that interdisciplinary
knowledge and and kind of you know uh
awareness that you you come from the
domain but you also know what kind of
technology can be used to help these
people or or to solve this challenge so
that's the opportunity we saw and of
course uh you know that's whole uh was
the genesis of ikey minds where we you
know it's it's basically a bio id or or
a tech led healthcare company a life
sciences company very very very focused
on you know bringing these two worlds
together and and try and see how we can
you know
basically leverage the the talent and
and
bridge and basically skill them to the
next level of job which is required
which is which is demanding and what
kind of you know uh uh skill sets are
required in the in the industry and
that's that's what we are doing
coming back to the investment uh in this
space it's it's really uh incredible at
this point of time in fact when i just
started i kind of got a couple of calls
from vcs and messages that you know they
want to they want to invest but that
time we had just the seed fund so i was
like i was so happy to see that yes
invest investors are looking at the
space quite you know uh uh uh i mean
they are seeing the future of return on
investment on this phase which wasn't
the case a decade back life sciences has
been always a very risky space to invest
in if you look at the other space like
fintech you know
there's a huge investment been pumped up
in last one or two decade but nothing
has been really happened on the health
tech or the life sciences side but now
what i've seen is like there are there
are very focused uh vcs has come in
angels have come in who are you know
advocating who are brand ambassadoring
who are really interested in spending on
this uh space and i think we we all have
seen that you know post code the way
things have changed the adoptions have
come and if you just look at the number
of startups in fact before this
i was just you know trying to figure out
some numbers and i was amazed to see
like there are almost 5 000 plus health
tech startups are born you know in in
india on the on the health care and
health tech side so that itself suggests
that you know how people are trying to
get into the space invest in the space
and and of course you know um for
freshers i would say
please open your ears and eyes and then
you know look at the opportunity and
just just sky is the limit in this space
yeah thanks
[Music]
that makes sense i i think uh with all
of that your experience and the points
that you have mentioned which is like uh
i would say
for an entrepreneur or person who is
thinking about to do something
with it like startups and all
um the interdisciplinary nature of
this
field is
kind of uh something that requires them
to know about so general awareness i
think uh awareness about investments
awareness about technology awareness
about what is happening in the fields
around it and what are the innovations
these are some of the very important
aspects someone who is diving into this
and thinking about to like you know do
this and again like another point that
we discussed about that having a prior
experience or doing these internships
where
where the startups are working uh
actually could help a lot of people a
lot of these students to overcome uh to
understand the challenges for say for
example first-hand challenges so i think
uh great uh value there uh to this to to
address this question and if uh
dr khannan can maybe add something to it
like how does he see because uh dr khan
you are working on the frontiers of
oncology research and using these new
technologies so how do you see this
market and how do you see that how what
kind of opportunities because what is
happening also is that like these uh
these specialized skill sets are
something that the post docs are getting
an exposure in the us so how do
students in india get exposed to uh
those cutting-edge technologies that are
that you are working on and there is a
scope of you know capacity and intake of
such students
thank you that's a that's a very good
point uh so if you live in u.s if you
are a student in a university either a
phd or a postcard
you frequently go almost every weekend
we used to have fridays and saturdays we
used to have like a institution-wide
meetings where you interact with
everybody
also we we get to travel we get to uh so
in oncology we go to three main
conferences uh american society for
hematology ash
and american society for clinical
unconscious ascot and aacr uh so if
you're a basic science guy
or doing some kind of product when you
go to ascr if you're a clinician you go
to asco and if you have a hematology
then you go to ash so and then if you
live in europe you go to esmo
so i had the opportunity of attending
all these uh conferences when i was in
u.s 10 years every year we used to go
all the meetings the university used to
sponsor my my pa used to sponsor one
thing i really missed after coming back
to india that physical presence of
attending these meetings is not
happening because it's too expensive
right to first you have to travel then
you have to book the flight tickets you
have to get the hotel and all that stuff
and then there's a conference
registration thing but one good thing
happened in the pandemic you know they
say uh every crisis comes with some lot
of bad things but also some good things
the good thing that happened many of
these conferences are now online and
virtual events have become the the main
stage right now we are in a virtual
event
no need to travel no need to spend money
and
you still have to pay certain
conferences they still charge you for
the rich which i don't understand they
still charge your registration fee but
it's a lot more economical than actually
physically traveling so highly encourage
the student community here
in your area of domain of expertise
follow these institutions these
organizations like we follow asia and
follow them on twitter only
so as soon as the event is announced
immediately registered so during this
meeting i just registered for a mit boot
camp that's specifically for healthcare
entrepreneurship
so it just took me five five minutes
when i was listening to sonali i was
just filling up the form on mit bootcamp
website so it doesn't take much time and
what i do is uh whenever i see some
notifications whenever you see some good
websites i highly recommend every every
organization whether it's a for-profit
or a non-profit
they advertise the webinars and cme
events for clinicians maybe not so very
common nowadays and they also have all
these global events like the 11 calling
event i was talking about i have been
attending london calling virtually since
2019 i i went london once or twice but i
didn't get the opportunity to attend the
live
nanopore conference all the nana four
community meetings london calling
everything i'm attending virtually the
good thing about nanopore they they have
the video section in the resources page
uh where you can watch all the videos uh
so you can also if you register you
attend in live you can also interact
with the audience interact with the
speakers
also you can interact with the with that
staff members you can ask all your towns
so like that many companies do that uh
so that's something an opportunity even
if you miss the live session but i still
register even if i cannot attend all the
meetings i will get a recorded session
they email me they get a recorded
session uh you know you can you can
watch it in your free time so subscribe
to newsletters any zoom link you see any
conference any webinar click the up
click the register button now
right that's the way that's the way to
stay connected because once you leave
academy and come to industry
nobody's nobody's keeping you up to date
right it's you have to take your own
initiatives uh to learn what's going
around in the rest of the world
especially for
people who are in india and other
emerging economies
who don't have access to travel
something happening in san diego
something happening in chicago obviously
i can't travel now the embassy is closed
uh they're not issuing visas for at
least one more year so it's a huge
backlog so but the same meetings are
available virtually
even if they charge a thousand dollars
or two thousand dollars i would say it's
totally worth it registered for the
meetings because
one thing you get access to all the
abstracts all the all the plenary
symposiums and everything plus you will
also
get the contacts the networking so most
of the time i'm not even listening to
the speakers i'm actually in the chat
box
talking to people you know on networking
so i highly encourage these three
strategies subscription to newsletters
attend as many webinars as possible and
when you attend a real live session uh
try to network with attendees so here we
have like more than 70 people in the
group so try to interact with them
direct message them
don't declare the
the common group uh do direct message to
the person you want to talk to so that's
my that's my three main takeaways uh
from this virtual meetings
that's how you stay connected that's how
you you stay up to date with what's
going on around the world so then you
are not left left behind right so you
are you are on par with your colleagues
in u.s and europe
yeah i think great great points and
hacks there i mean we do know about it
but we don't know how to utilize them
and where to find these resources so
i think one of the key to finding
information is also
searching properly searching for these
keywords that uh that are necessary for
you to know exactly where these
resources are and most of the things are
available online and as dr khan and
rightly said that how the poet
19
pandemic has changed
the entire way of
you know knowledge knowledge transfer
and also gaining access to all those
events especially on an online setting
the opportunities are a lot there's a
lot of opportunity and many of these
events are also free for students and
users that and also recordings are
available on youtube so there's a huge
resource out there
where you can learn about these new
technologies and
maybe
connect with people over the link over
linkedin who are working on these
specific technologies because uh i think
that is one great reason place to find
people who are working on it something
that you include that like motivates you
and then connect and then have a
meaningful discussion so i mean with
that i would go to
uh go to kalyani and uh ask her that
how's her experience in mentor's hype
and
uh and
how do you see kalyani and very good
evening how do you see this uh academia
to industry transition and those points
like when you prepare to be a to be
like maybe get a highlighted by the
industry or get your profile being
highlighted so that the relevant person
can reach out to you or you can reach
out to relevant person as in and get
that impression
thank you so much
can you hear me
yes yes hey good evening everyone and
thank you so much for giving this
opportunity and it's great to be talking
to a lot of upcoming scientists over
here so i was listening to sonali and dr
ishivi and nidhi before this
so i think all these things that people
have told
has a lot of value that they have
brought into this space for the students
who are here
so quickly adding something to talk
about dr chevy was just saying about
conferences so
i think students can relate to this when
we were students we also used to think
of conferences as an outing that when
you are going for a conference you it's
more like okay i'm going to isc for a
conference so
i'm going to go there and have fun and
all but what dr shibi has told just now
is something that you should all know
that conferences are not just for fun
not food and all it's more about
networking over there and the and one
more point that i would like to add
along with the three points that he has
mentioned is
you can target people over there so
suppose if you want to connect with dr
shibi sometime on a personal level he
just mentioned that he is going for a
boot camp and if you are interested in
something like that that's the place
that you can target that is just an
example that i'm giving you so if you
have been following a professor for your
next post doc or for a
for a job position going forward for
somebody who is into industry
make sure you find out you follow them
on linkedin
keep following up that which events are
they going to attend in future you keep
track of those events attend those
events so that you have a context for a
meaningful conversation with them when
you go there
and even when you want to connect you
can say that okay i heard you in this
particular conference you spoke about
this thing the moment you put this
personalized messages over there that
will bring the life that is what will
bring the limelight to you
so i have been into industry like i have
transitioned i've done my phd my postdoc
then i was in a health care startup that
i was working in
for three years i was there then i
completely pivoted now i'm a product
manager in a
uh in a video publishing house from us
so these transitions so you can see i
have been in the trajectory where i have
experienced all these things
and i would strongly recommend that
networking is something that plays a big
role mohamed and i'm sure you also
understand because you're also in
industry now
so that is something that students
should definitely think on
and one point that i want to elaborate a
little bit on what finally google drive
was also indicating about mindset so
this is something where we are all
getting stuck
it is not a very big thing people have
been making a
you know huge human cry around
transitioning from academia to industry
it is not very difficult if you are
taking the right approach if you have
that mindset if you are prepared for it
you know even before your masters when
you join masters what kind of field you
are interested in you know take
internships everybody has been telling
about it so there's nothing new about it
but when you're taking internship
when you are looking at the particular
job that you are doing there also look
at people around you
does anything else apart from your own
job impress you you know you can maybe
look at some product project manager
brings there in your company and you can
look up to them you can see okay this
person is doing this i would like to do
a job like this
set goals like that and then take a you
know top down approach so that you can
make a career path for yourself that's
something that we keep telling our
mentees always that the problem with our
system is we are never taught to
think beyond our next degree you know
the moment you take admission in phd you
are like okay five years i'll just focus
on my phd no that's not the right thing
and that is not something that you
should be doing you should know what is
your next step going to be after that
and you start preparing for it so like
life is like a chess game so when you
have heard that in a chess of you know a
grand master will prepare for a move
seven moves ahead so why can't you do
that in your life i'm sure your life is
more important than a chess game
i think these are couple of things that
people should start focusing on
you know and you know we were talking
about the health care segment it is
booming like anything and it is not the
you not the boom that we have seen in it
it is going beyond that because
something that is related to us that all
of us can relate to
and even the investors are seeing this
as dr sonali was also indicating
i actually urge students always that you
go for a startup job first because my
first job was in a startup
you get to learn a lot you know you are
when you are in a big company it is like
you are given a small chunk of work and
you do the same work day in day out
and i'm sure doctor smiley would agree
with me on this that if you if you are
in a startup you get to wear many hats
you get so much of exposure you get to
learn so many things so early in your
career if you're hustling at that level
you learn so much about yourself about
your domain about your industry that
going forward becomes much more easier
for you at least that's what i feel when
i have transitioned from you know
academia to industry then to another
category all together so these are a
couple of things that we should keep our
minds open to keep looking around people
you know who are there what kind of
upskilling they are doing you know
upskilling is a very important thing
that we should always focus on you know
that is where omics research you know
omics logic comes into picture pine
barker comes into picture you can you
should keep up skilling yourself never
get stuck even after your phd or postdoc
or masters i did my post doc a three
year postdoc and even after that i
wanted top skill i wanted to grow beyond
that i didn't want to get stuck after
saying that okay postdoc is the highest
degree what more can somebody do
but i wanted to break that thing because
i wanted to reach out for more
so never think
never think that you know i have done it
this and this is enough it's never
enough there's always something to learn
uh i think that uh answers your question
yes absolutely and uh there is another
important question i'll come to that but
yes absolutely you're right and we got
to know about like i would highlight
networking one of the things that all of
the speakers have i put emphasis on and
the different ways to do this and what
is a meaningful way to do this because
we all try to do different things but
there is a structure to it and that's
what also
uh something that nidhi showed us
in our presentation that there is a
structure to it and you can get trained
so there are a few questions i mean
which are quite relevant i think um uh
one question which i could maybe go to
sonali about so uh
uh paraks segal she's asking that uh
what are the opportunities for women
uh on how one can do research in
bioinformatics or data science while
working in working from home because
it's it's also like an opportunity for
women who are like at the early stages
and may be involved in family and have
those limitations that we are very much
aware in india
yeah so i mean
as a subject it's not really women or
men it's about you know the
bioinformatics so if i if i would just
you know talk about bioinformatics as a
subject it's a very interdisciplinary
area where you need knowledge of biology
where you need knowledge of
computational biology a bit of coding
skills you know depending on
which uh which direction you are
so you can have a combination or or you
know it can skew between from very
domain side to the the coding side or in
between anywhere of this the whole you
know uh scale of the bioinformatics uh
there is definitely you know i mean
since it's it's a very collaborative uh
uh space and it's it's a very very uh
scientific area uh there's definitely a
need for you know be there along with
the team working along with the
scientists because you are so
bioinformatics is not the other areas
where you know like the id right like
where you just work on some project
remotely yes that can be done for some
time but there would be some touch
points and also it depends on the how
the projects are designed like some of
the projects which we do basically we
have a project manager who would be
client-facing who would be you know
understanding and that person is
basically who understand the biology and
the life sciences right and they would
relay this to the data scientist guys
and the data scientist guys can sit
anywhere across the country or the globe
and can actually work on the the logics
or the the problem statement which is
defined to them right so so if somebody
is interested work remotely yes there is
absolutely you know a possibility to
work remotely on the bioinformatics area
as well but then again i mean you know
are you just willing to do the coding
part of it or you also want to you know
go a little bit more advanced on the the
science part of it right so so i i think
that's and that's the the beauty of it
right you just don't want to restrict
yourself on on you know knowing the
algorithm or you know building the
algorithm because you're working on a
very interesting data these are not like
you know any other non-biological data
these are not these are very live very
very interactive data and when you work
with data you would want to work
collaboratively you would want to work
with the scientific team who has
actually generated the data i mean let's
say for example of um ngs sequencing
right so so you get all all the data
coming out from your illumina or
nanopore or whatever sequencing
machine and then you try and analyze
this data but then you will also have to
understand how the data has been
generated what was the objective of it
what was the outcome we are trying to
achieve so there's basically a lot of
interactions and collaborations happens
among us but having said that there is
definitely a possibility a one team can
sit remotely and can you know work on
the the coding part of it as long as
they they can effectively communicate
with the scientist you know remotely
it's absolutely possible to to deliver
even even the bioinformatics projects as
well
perfect perfect i think that that kind
of answers the question that
once wanted to ask because what is
happening is that like we saw that that
many especially in the context of women
who has
maybe dropped out and have a long gap
they're coming back and saying that
bioinformatics is something that could
be done effectively in a home setting
and maybe in a hybrid setting so make
sense thank you so much nali for that
for that expertise expert advice
now uh a question i mean uh
for dr khan as he was talking about
networking so there's a question by one
of the student and it makes sense like
after you network with the expert in the
field
what tips do you have on sustaining that
professional relationship for a long
time of approach because we do start
with that but how to sustain that like
how do you find those you know ways to
make keep it engaging engaged and give
that engagement for a longer time or
longer
timeline
yes that's a very good question so
during the conferences or webinars we
make the initial meeting and greeting
right but how do you continue that
relationship outside the webinar uh so
the best place is linkedin obviously
linkedin on twitter so twitter
uh
i was not using i was one of the early
adopters i'm like
5000th person who joined linkedin and
500 person who joined twitter so i'm
like always looking for new tech and i'm
one of the early adopters of all these
new technologies in fact i was using
whatsapp before people in india knew
about whatsapp
rights i'm a very very early adopter but
then i stopped using twitter in between
because it was full of junk uh then
later on i realized the entire
scientific community is on twitter right
so if you want real-time collaboration
instantaneous response from anybody for
example clive brown cto of nanopore i
simply clicked follow
follow one second within five seconds he
followed me back i was like wow the city
of nanapur is following me back you know
you and then instantly we connected when
we were talking similarly you know
during kobe uh i was working on the
pancreas vaccine
mrna vaccine so a lot of interest in
mrna vaccine nowadays because of the
success stories of eisen and modern so
that is this dr florian kramer and he
was putting all this and also eric
dobble and all these other guys they're
putting all the latest updates on kobit
research so i kept following them and
when they put something interesting then
i engaged with them right i messaged i
reply to them and they replay back
so that's that's that's the key metric
so it's not just you putting
bombarding them with messages they have
to reply back whereas if you take people
like elon musk
millions of people follow him he never
replies to anybody he very rarely
replies unless it's some some something
maybe unique you know something out of
the ordinary he never replaced anybody
that's not an engagement the engagement
is you message somebody and they reply
so there's a to and fro that's a
conversations are happening so social
media is the best place to go don't
waste your time on instagram or facebook
focus on these two platforms linkedin on
twitter
linkedin you'll also get the history of
the particular person which university
they went to where are they working
right now right and if they are hiring
so nowadays they have that hiring tag
and similarly employees and students and
postdocs also looking for a job i'm open
for opportunities you can put a tag on a
profile picture uh that kind of enables
specific linkedin one one big thing
which i recommend everybody is uh follow
or connect with your mentors and peers
and ask them to give recommendations
similarly you give recommendations to
them so it's like i give you a
recommendation you give me a
recommendation oh it's a it's a social
exchange
and also update your skills make your
profile 100 i've seen many students
sending me cvs and other things uh
because no people are always looking for
jobs uh but then you then you open the
profile they don't even put the picture
on the on the
profile right
so that's then suddenly
imagine the human resource person or
somebody who is interested or let's say
you are applying for a post up job with
the faculty they don't even see your
face
how do you how do you expect them to
respond to you right so it's all about
the human connection
so keep your profile 100 updated so if
you take any online course you don't for
example you understand for example then
you can post it in link green and you
can share the put the hashtags put the
links and everything automatically you
will get that recognition right it's all
about social proofing recognition you
need to be in control of your own domain
and you have to showcase that you are
going that extra distance you're taking
initiatives uh to learn things and
exchange ideas and connect with your
peers also connect with the faculty so
it's not like suddenly pop out of
nowhere and say hey dr kanan can you
give me a job it doesn't work like that
right even even if you have some
openings no right there's so many
qualified candidates why should i pick
you over 10 other candidates who have
gone through the
selection process
so you have to stand out from the crowd
how do you stand up from the crowd
you have to let your voice be here at
the same time you want to engage with
the audience so we we have a saying in
startups in entrepreneurship your
network equals your net worth right so
build your network and these two
platforms are amazing so in twitter what
you do if you see any check mark blue
checkmarks the verified accounts
unfollow everybody unfollow all the
celebrities and follow the guys whenever
they play like i don't follow elon musk
i don't follow jeff pesos i don't follow
bill gates but i follow bill and marina
against foundation because the
foundation will put announcement when is
the next grant coming i need to know the
deadline so that i can apply the program
follow the people you need unfollow
everybody you don't need uh that's the
best case scenario same with linkedin
don't randomly follow people don't
randomly
spam messages connect with them on on
that particular topic that's being
discussed right so that's there has to
be some relevancy in the connects that's
my that's my take on that so linkedin
and twitter two best places to be right
now uh also learning learning
opportunities plenty of learning
opportunities
so many tips and tricks for the
community it has been a great experience
dr khannan and kalyani and
sanati thank you so much
add a couple of actionable tips over
there do we have time for that
yes yes of course i was coming back to
you
okay great so uh just adding on to
whatever doctor should be said so for
students that you know when we mentor
them sometimes we tell them these things
they don't know where to start and
linkedin as a profile when you just join
it can become a little overwhelming you
know for anybody who has just joined you
so few actionable tips i would like to
give here if you have a pen and paper
make sure you you know make a note of it
so when you're connecting with somebody
suppose if you are sending me a friend
request or a connection request there
make sure you mention it there you know
hi kalyani i really heard you over the
this particular home's logic conference
that i attended oh you know i want to
know more from you i want to learn from
you your profile is inspiring pick up
something from my profile that you can
connect with like okay you worked in
systems biology i'm also currently
working on systems biology
try to make a personal connect over
there in some fashion you know it should
have uh it should not be just like you
know you have just clicked on the button
then you have not made an effort until
unless you make an effort from your end
how would the other person realize that
you are sincere in your efforts so that
is the first thing never send a
connection request without a message in
it and as dr shibi was indicating that
you cut you engage with them so how do
you engage with them enough on a
continuous basis you comment on their
post don't just comment saying that okay
this post is inspiring thanks for
sharing put your own thoughts to it so
if you have done that five times the
sixth time the person would know that
okay this person has been commenting on
my post so if at all an opportunity
arises where you have to reach out to
them for a certain you know job or any
favor you can always stay and that
person would recognize you because oh
kalyani i've seen her she keeps
commenting on my post that means she has
some knowledge about the field so these
are the ways that you're establishing
your credibility over there so when you
are on linkedin you have you also have
to post there so if suppose you are
interested in cancer biology and a new
paper has come up in cancer biology why
don't you post it there along with some
thoughts of your own that what does this
research mean what is going to be a
future impact of this research overall
cancer health care so the moment you put
in some meaningful thoughts there that's
when the person realizes that okay this
person is intellectually sound they have
some credibility in the field they
understand the feel and once you keep
making those kind of engagement that's
when your name is visible always you
know you are somewhere in the radar so
even if you are not connected with them
on a day in day out basis at least you
know you are there on their feed every
time they can keep seeing your name
so these are some of the ways that you
can you know highlight your profile you
know kind of create a brand for yourself
when you're on linkedin and similar goes
with their twitter also you have to keep
engaging with their post and of course
meaningful engagement whenever i'm
saying engagement it is meaningful
engagement where you write something
about that they have done or they have
posted and how your comment is adding a
value to it so keep these things in mind
whenever you are going to linkedin next
time
perfect thank you so much
for all those insights and it has been
an honor
to be a part of this uh panel and to be
a part of with all of you uh here uh so
i i am really i'm thoughtful and i think
that students have been
and also like
the faculty have been able to gain some
of these points and could maybe transfer
this knowledge further and students can
apply some of these points and
get the outcomes they are looking for or
looking towards because they
i mean there is a there is a sense of
doing things quickly in this new
generation and uh without putting the
effort which is required in there so uh
if there is a constant effort you will
get to the results and that's what
experts are saying again thank you so
much to the
panelists for being being a part of this
research symposium and dr khannan is
again filling another form so yes thank
you again
for for being here and helping all of us
and we will be able to see you again
very soon and maybe to talk to you on
different opportunities